uh we're right let's start with this
pack now this story fascinates for me
Jonah Hill
emotionally abusing his ex Sarah Brodie
Michaela welcome to Piers Morgan on
sensor first of all as a newbie
um so what I've read I mean Sarah Brady
seems to be relentlessly posting all
their old text message exchanges I just
don't think he's on anyway why secondly
when I've read them all Jonah Hill's
probably entitled to just lay down some
boundaries isn't he and if she doesn't
want to go along with it well fine and
she clearly didn't really so they split
up and that's it and they move on but
you won't move on and that must shame
him why well when I first read the text
I thought maybe Jonah Hill was being
unreasonable because if you're going to
date a surfer and they put up swimsuit
photos you can't be that shocked by it
but that was before I knew that it was a
year and a half later he's just had a
kid with his girlfriend so I would just
say she's she's looking for attention
obviously so he was probably right about
the swimsuit photos in the first place
being irritated by them because it was
probably for attention given she won't
give it up now don't be cat I mean
why are we reading all this I mean they
split up he's met someone else he's
become a father with somebody else I
read them they're not like abusive
abusive it's just him saying I would
prefer you don't do this this kind of
conversation goes on in every
relationship doesn't it yeah I feel like
now everything is has to be some
specific therapy word and yeah that side
or another he maybe was I think he was
being kind of a jerk in that
conversation don't start dating a surfer
if you're not comfortable with these
things but also yes yes and she's
clearly looking for attention because
she keeps posting more and more things
cringe making and none of us I don't
care who you are none of us would look
awesome
based on our worst text we've ever seen
I mean I would but Cyrus uh nobody wants
to see their dirty linen airing on
Instagram stories minute by minute she's
posting this stuff all day long well to
be fair she's posting excerpts yeah yes
of the text she's not posting her stuff
because typically since she wants to use
big words like abuse because abuse has
changed a lot because I need to call
some of my football coaches and I have
to bring them on this show because they
didn't talk to me that way about
boundaries and if you don't like you do
it my way they use cuss words and stuff
so the sensitivity of this is basically
um
just she's just coming off looking
really thirsty I mean she says in one of
the posts this is not abuse he said this
is a warning to all girls if your
partner's talking to you like this make
an Exit Plan love you all call me if you
need near well he made the Exit Plan he
set up boundaries but let's here's the
thing in the argument about the um she's
a surfer okay but Surfers usually wear a
wetsuit when they surf competitively she
was taking pictures and and Kat did this
great she did this great prank on social
media where she took a picture with a
black box by where her butt was and then
when you swiped it it was an even bigger
one so but there was no black box with
her she's the only bathing suit photo
that I have on the internet we're
talking about bathing suits let's talk
about Miss Netherlands at the weekend
Ricky Valerie uh Coley who was a
transgender entrant to miss Netherlands
competition uh won the title so a
biological male has been voted Miss
Netherlands and will now take part in
Miss Universe Michaela your thoughts I
hope he wins Miss Universe I'm I'm
kidding I'm kidding it it's I don't even
know how to react to these situations
because women fought so hard to get
where we are today I was just looking at
the picture of the Boston marathon
runner in 1967 and it's this woman and
she's being grabbed by men on the track
because women weren't allowed to compete
that's where it started and now we're
here and there are men competing in our
Sports and I have no idea how feminism
came full it is it's so bizarre and Cat
I mean Only Yesterday Megan rapino one
of the great female sports stars in
American history came out on as she
retired this might be convenient timing
because it won't apply to her and said
I'd be very happy if trans athlete
Sports women come and play in the
American women's team well fine but what
happens if they're all 11 biological
males representing the American women's
team I mean this can't be right surely I
think what's even worse is people saying
that if you have some issue with with a
biological male competing in sports then
the only reason for that is that you're
transphobic and not the research that
you can point to that shows that someone
who's gone through male puberty could
have various advantages over a
biological woman in these activities in
Esports it's not a zero-sum game when
it's these conversations there's
scholarships there's different things on
the line there and I think that that
really just taints the whole entire
issue when it comes to pageants I do
want to get on the record that I think
pageants are lame right I mean that
could be a perfectly reasonable argument
that they're all lame but Sarah's you
know
every aspect of Womanhood is for one of
a better phrase under attack from the
trans Lobby that basically want to have
their rights superseding women's rights
to just be competing against other
females now to be fair my opinion is
going to be skewed because I am I do
identify as a phobic
phobic on everything so the idea that in
this what does it say about women that a
man can just switch and be a woman in
the inside of six months win everything
so you know where are the feminists
turns out the feminists are the alpha
males because we're the only ones
complaining about this right and I think
it's whenever you always have to follow
the money whenever somebody comes out
and says I think this and doesn't make
sense with the soccer player
she I guarantee you if a trans man took
her job yes that would not be the
conversation oh it may happen it'd be
you know and it's just like the same
thing with like the Equal Pay thing when
you do the math they actually are making
more than the men so it just goes back
to narratives they say things there's no
way I don't care what makeup hair
whatever that any man to Transitions is
going to be more beautiful than a woman
it's just not Pageants the scholarships
the modeling jobs that go with it it's
political you you can't tell me like
that and I don't know that person could
be the nicest person in the world but
there's no way that is the best way of a
woman also when Megan rapino talks about
this she likes to position herself as
all about equality she fought a very
good campaign for the women players to
be paid the same as the men great okay
they get big audiences they're world
champions I can sign up to that but
what's equal about allowing people with
an obvious physical advantage to come in
and decimate women's sport it's not
equal so you can be you can be all about
equality right to the point you say this
stuff then you're not about equality um
talking of equal cat and we don't know
the answer to this question but Elon
Musk has challenged Mark Zuckerberg not
just to a cage fight but he's now up to
the ante he said Zuck is a cook I don't
know it means a [__] is it you tweeted
Sunday night I propose a literal dick
measuring contest
speaking of differences in gender women
don't do this women are never like in a
business dispute and they're like oh
yeah we'll pull your pants down because
I got what I got going on is better than
you uh this is just him being a bro you
know I don't think they ever actually
fight in a cage match I think that Elon
Musk is having a little bit of fun with
this and I don't think they ever
actually do it because what do you make
of this whole threads thing 100 million
people have signed up in the space of
the few days I mean Mark Zuckerberg is
taking the challenge to to Elon Musk is
Elon Musk in trouble with Twitter do you
think
so 100 million people signed up in a few
days but there's 2.35 billion people on
Instagram I don't know if that type of
conversion at like five percent is
something to be that proud of and I've
been on the platform and
compare I don't think this is
interesting I guess that would be the
nice way of saying it I don't think it's
as interesting as as Twitter but also
Taurus I mean Zuckerberg's trying to
make it it's going to be a place for
nice conversation there is no social
media platform that's nice yeah they're
all vile aren't they all of them even
Facebook doesn't seem like lotion in the
basket type nice in the other direction
well I would like to argue no women
don't pull them out and put them on the
table so to speak but they're always
judging each other by the way they're
dressed and talking about outfits
look at her shoes
yeah they're delicious they're not
actually yeah no manner no no two no
one's going to pay money you see Zuck
and Elon no no
Absolutely I'll see the injuries I would
see the entrance I'm telling you right
now stage fright lights
I wouldn't pay as much money as I would
pay currently to see Captain Fon tour
which starts next week oh yeah I'm
announcing even more dates on Thursday
how many days you doing
I'm honored to still have you on the
show of course thank you thank you
Taurus thank you Miguel I love to see
you